et avec nous pour ce club spécial
consacré à la réforme des retraites de
sénateurs qui vont débattre de cette
réforme Marie-Claire de la contrib
bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes sénatrice socialiste
de Paris Stéphane le Ruby bonjour
bonjour merci d'être là sénateur les
républicains des Bouches-du-Rhône et
vous allez donc des battes de cette
réforme des retraites qui arrivent au
Sénat aujourd'hui début des débats dans
l'hémicycle à 14h30 d'abord Samia on va
faire un point avec vous sur les enjeux
politiques de cette réforme dans quel
état d'esprit les sénateurs vont
l'aborder mais plutôt sereinement a
priori Oriane puisque la majorité
sénatoriale promet des débats plus
apaisés qu'à l'Assemblée nationale il
faut dire que cette majorité de droite
et du centre elle est favorable on le
sait à la réforme qui prévoit de
reporter l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans elle compte donc bien
la beauté cette réforme le Sénat doit
donner une autre image que celle qui a
donné l'assemblée a déclaré hier Bruno
Retailleau patron des sénateurs LR le
job des sénateurs je cite toujours ce
n'est pas de discuter à l'infini c'est
voter a-t-il rajouté à gauche en
revanche on fait front commun contre la
réforme des retraites socialiste
communiste et écologistes ont tenu à une
conférence de presse commune pour
afficher leur unité nous allons nous
battre contre cette réforme que nous
considérons comme une réforme de
régression sociale à prévenus Patrick
canard président du groupe socialiste
alors la gauche sénatoriale et laquelle
vous appartenez Marie-Pierre delagontrie
elle est donc elle a décidé de s'opposer
à cette réforme des retraites mais vous
êtes minoritaire au Sénat on le sait
alors quel va être votre stratégie au
Sénat notre stratégie ça va être d'abord
de défendre
tous les il y a une très belle photo là
qui s'affiche derrière vous c'est
centaines de milliers et de millions de
manifestants qui s'inquiètent et on le
voit bien on est très au-delà des
manifestations habituelles on le voit
par exemple dans les villes moyennes où
il y a d'habitude peu de mouvement des
gens qui se mobilisent parce que tout le
monde est inquiet et tout s'oppose quand
je dis tout le monde les sondages je
crois ce qui va mais dit 72 ou 78 %
d'un dernier baromètre de ça pour que
l'excellin
majorité des français surtout posés et
ça tient toujours bref donc nous ce que
nous voulons c'est effectivement qui dit
ce débat sur le fond qui n'a pas pu se
tenir à l'Assemblée pour d'autres
raisons on peut y revenir si vous voulez
mais peu importe parce que je pense
qu'il est très important que
les Français sachent très exactement la
position des uns des autres et qui a
voté quoi et moi je le dis à nos
collègues LR nous aurons un débat très
sérieux robuste solide mais je crains
qu'il ne décide de jouer un peu le rôle
des idiots utiles du gouvernement
aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron de toute
façon au fond n'a pas une idéologie
extrêmement déterminée ce qu'il veut
c'est que son texte soit voté il fait
parfois preuve d'ailleurs d'une espèce
d'obstination un petit peu déraisonnable
bref et donc les sénateurs LR LR en
général voit une possibilité de
s'engouffrer mais au final si par hasard
le texte est voté voilà et bien les
sénateurs et les auront permis Emmanuel
Macron de faire voter sa réforme des
retraites or les gens qui manifestent
dans la rue c'est pas malheureusement
pour nous que des électeurs de gauche
donc nous allons régulièrement
interpellé sur tous les sujets les
carrières longues les femmes etc etc
évidemment mais sur la méthode vous
risquez de jouer les idiots utiles du
gouvernement c'est ce que dit
on est toujours cohérent et constant par
rapport à ce qu'on a défendu qu'Emmanuel
Macron échangé d'avis et rejoindre
l'oppositions
ça le regarde effectivement je rejoins
madame de la Contrie il a pas de il y a
pas de corpus idéologique d'Emmanuel
Macron et ça se voit bien mais ce qui ce
qu'il faut noter c'est que on aura des
débats apaisé serein sur l'ensemble des
sujets il y avait un articles et c'est
20 articles doivent être étudiés
pourquoi parce que il doit y avoir ce
texte est incomplet
est imparfait on doit
majorité des avancées également sociales
pour nos concitoyens pour les rassurer
pour voir que clairement cette réforme
elle est nécessaire on l'a vu par
rapport à l'évolution démographique mais
dans le même temps elle doit être la
plus juste possible donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle la droite sénatoriale
effectivement portera des amendements
par exemple sur la carrière hachée des
femmes sur les maires de famille puisque
ce sont malheureusement pour l'heure les
victimes de ce texte nous porterons
également le sujet des carrières longues
enfin on va parler du fond mais sur la
méthode est-ce que vous
noter que il n'y ait pas de vote au
Sénat
quand on regarde le paysage
institutionnel le Sénat et le seul Paul
institutionnel stable aujourd'hui
regardez l'état de l'exécutif regardez
le spectacle à l'assemblée
du Sénat il y a toujours eu des
discussions de fond et on arrive
toujours à voter les textes ça serait
une inédit sous la Cinquième République
moi je dénonce la procédure qui a été
utilisée du 47-1 sur un sujet aussi
essentiel le temps programmé n'est pas
la bonne méthode mais encore une fois on
a une responsabilité sinon on ouvre une
crise parlementaire et démocratique sans
précédent soit Cinquième République
nous on souhaite que le débat se
prolonge autant que nécessaire
effectivement peut-être pour les
téléspectateurs l'article que vous
évoquez c'est un article qui contraint
de terminer le dimanche 12 à minuit on
éteint la lumière terminée quel que soit
le stade de la discussion et c'est
effectivement un problème alors moi
j'entends que le Sénat la tradition etc
etc autant je suis pour le débat de fond
que aucune question ne soit escamotée
qu'il y ait des votes autant moi je ne
sais pas si au final ce texte sera voté
je ne sais pas et c'est vrai que vous
avez raison non mais comment dire nous
nous ne sommes pas nous n'avons pas
comme but de guerre de décider que
l'Assemblée ou le Sénat ne
fonctionnerait pas ce n'est pas notre
notre ADN politique à la différence de
certaines autres formations politiques
sauf que vous avez raison de dire que
c'est inédit mais c'est inédit de faire
une réforme des retraites qui mettent
autant de personnes dans la rue et avec
un système de de législation qui est
très originale et un petit peu choquant
donc beaucoup de choses sont inédites
c'est inédit effectivement que
l'assemblée n'est pas pu voter et
peut-être que le Sénat ne pourra pas
voter et ensuite on verra parce que il
faut préciser peut-être que parce que
nous on est là dedans de du matin au
soir donc on connaît ça par coeur mais
peut-être préciser aux gens qui nous
regardent de bon matin que si le Sénat
ne votait pas bon il y a une procédure
parlementaire etc très bien mais le
gouvernement aurait la possibilité pas
l'obligation de prendre ses dispositions
par ordonnance bien donc on serait
encore dans un autre scénario donc voilà
nous on ne se fixe pas d'objectif
particulier ce qu'on veut c'est que le
débat ait lieu sur chaque point tout le
temps et nous serons absolument
intransigeants y compris avec le
ministre qui était autrefois socialiste
qui semble avoir totalement oublié les
valeurs pour qu'elle il s'est engagé en
politique je parle d'Olivier du sol mais
est-ce que c'est un problème si la
majorité sénatoriale et la présidence du
Sénat accélère les débats pour arriver
au bout est-ce que vous vous considérez
que c'est
simple ce n'est pas possible
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait lorsqu'on
regarde de près j'ai vu que fleurissait
dans les articles cette théorie qui est
là aussi je me permets de faire les
sous-titres le fait que la présidence de
séance pourrait limiter le nombre
d'intervenants sur chaque sujet à un
intervenant favorable un intervenant
défavorable je résume sauf que c'est
très très compliqué à mettre en oeuvre
parce qu'il faut consulter le Sénat il
faut que les groupes puissent s'exprimer
voter sur le principe même d'appliquer
cette mesure et le Conseil
constitutionnel est très exigeant sur ce
point il dit que les groupes de position
doivent pouvoir s'exprimer bref nous
sommes avec un texte qui est sans doute
inconstitutionnel sans rentrer dans les
détails parce que la procédure qui a été
choisie n'est pas adaptée etc etc et si
en plus le Sénat le président du Sénat
s'embarquait il y a pas d'autres mots
dans une procédure totalement aléatoire
et fragile cela renforcerait
l'inconstitutionnalité alors avoir fait
tout ça pour avoir au final un Intex
censuré par le Conseil constitutionnel
là je me permettrai de dire
qu'effectivement et LR et la présidence
du Sénat aurait joué un rôle un petit
peu voilà ça aurait été piégé par son
propre raisonnement non je pense pas que
ça soit la volonté du président archer
l'ensemble des groupes politiques à bien
conscience que il faut aller sur un
débat serein des bas de fonds on est
regardé par des millions de Français il
y en a qui sont également dans la rue le
spectacle qui a été donné à l'Assemblée
nationale ne se reproduira pas encore
une fois au Sénat on se connaît assez
suffisamment entre groupes politiques
donc moi j'ai tout confiance à
l'intelligence collective pour aboutir
au vote de ce texte parce que
effectivement et je rejoins encore une
fois madame de la Contrie attention
parce qu'on arrive dans une procédure
après tellement fragile sur la
légitimité du texte soit par 49,3 soit
par ordonnance sur ses traits techniques
mais ça veut dire que c'est un passage
en force sur une réforme aussi
essentielle ce n'est pas possible on a
déjà une crise sociale sans précédent
dans dans le pays il faut vraiment faire
preuve de pédagogie c'est tout le rôle
des parlementaires également on va
rentrer dans le fond du texte évidemment
au cœur de cette réforme et à l'aéroport
d'allège légal de départ le fameux
article 7 qui sera examiné après la
journée du 7 mars c'est l'accord que qui
a été trouvé entre les sénateurs vous
pensez que ça peut changer les débats le
fait de d'examiner cet article après
cette journée de mobilisation
nous notre notre boussole c'est
effectivement de discuter avec les
syndicats c'est le mouvement syndical je
note par ailleurs au passage que là où
autrefois le pôle de de raison de
dialogue de stabilité de régulation
c'était le Parlement et dans la rue
parfois y compris parce qu'il y avait
des des dérapages les choses étaient
beaucoup plus compliquées aujourd'hui
c'est l'inverse quand même problème
c'est-à-dire que tant mieux moi je suis
ravi que les manifestations soient à la
fois fournies et se passe dans de bonnes
conditions et nous avons une inter
syndicale avec des responsables
syndicaux qui sont enfin dont on peut
être assez fier j'ai envie de dire même
si on ne partage pas leurs opinions donc
nous nous dialoguons avec eux et
effectivement cette journée du 7 mars
personne ne sait très exactement comment
elle va se dérouler ce qui va se
produire est-ce que des mouvements de
grève vont être initiés au-delà de ce
que nous avons pu déjà connaître combien
de une centaine de voir de millions de
personnes il y aura dans la rue bref
donc comme l'article clé enfin clé
emblématique c'est cet article 7 sur le
report de l'âge de 62 à 64 ans
effectivement nous nous souhaiterions
que nous puissions d'abord voir quel est
le degré d'intérêt des Français par
rapport à cela la mobilisation de du 7
mars avant de l'examiner pour pour être
encore une fois pour nous le Parlement
doit être l'écho et le porte-voix du
sentiment des Français et pas l'inverse
cette journée du 7 mars
fondamentalement il faudra mesurer en
fait le mécontentement des Français là
aussi il y a le rôle des corps
intermédiaires et il faut saluer les
représentants syndicaux qui ont pu faire
preuve de responsabilité
durant ces semaines de mécontentement et
de et de conflits sociaux maintenant je
dis attention parce que le fait d'avoir
des objectifs de repousser après le 7
mars la lecture et l'examen de l'article
7 il y a quand même des articles
suivants qui sont assez essentiels
notamment pour les avancées sociales je
pense la pension de réversion pour les
adultes handicapés qui malheureusement
ont perdu les deux parents
toutes ces avancées sociales sont après
cet article donc il faudrait pas non
plus rabougrir raccourcir le débat sur
ces sujets aussi essentiels pardon le
gouvernement peut décider de prolonger
au-delà du 12 il faut quand même
préciser ce point donc je crois non je
crois que tous les groupes enfin je ne
sais pas mais je suis persuadé que les
groupes seraient preneurs de ce que le
débat dure au-delà du 12 on va rester
sur cet âge de départ on va voir ce
qu'on pense les Français concernés par
cette réforme Jonathan Dupriez est allé
rencontrer une assistante maternelle et
une opticienne toutes deux concernée par
le passage à 64 ans mais qui vous allez
le voir ne l'accueille pas de la même
façon
dans les Yvelines c'est ici à son
domicile que travaille angélique emeret
46 ans
angélique est assistante maternelle
depuis 20 ans un métier au contact des
enfants qu'elle apprécie au quotidien
qu'est-ce que j'aime
le partage avec les enfants qui nous le
rendent super bien
le côté humain
les relations avec les parents mais le
métier comporte aussi de lourdes
contraintes des gros horaires 7h à 18h
tous les jours et des difficultés
physiques liées à la manipulation des
enfants malgré cela les assistantes
maternelles ne tomberaient pas sous le
coup des critères de pénibilité de la
nouvelle réforme des retraites alors
pour Angélique travailler deux ans de
plus et partir à 64 ans contre 62
initialement et tout simplement un
concevable on n'est pas à l'abri que le
corps
ne sèche plus
malgré les mêmes si on a des douleurs
rien dit que une épaule va pas lâcher et
là du coup ça met quand même en danger
les enfants à 64 ans
même plus parce que je pense que ça ira
peut-être plus quand on va se battre
pour que non mais bon à une heure de là
Champigny-sur-Marne Déborah wargon
fait-elle un métier qu'elle juge
beaucoup moins pénible moi j'ai trouvé
que ça c'était bien à mes deux ans plus
je peux sans problème moi ça c'est
agréable j'aime le contact avec les
clients je ne m'imagine même pas et en
fait j'ai très peur d'être à la retraite
parce que j'ai très peur de m'ennuyer
soutien d'Emmanuel Macron à la
présidentielle la chef d'entreprise loue
le courage du chef de l'État de mener
une réforme quelle voie comme
indispensable pour sauver le système par
répartition ça fait partie même de
l'essence même de la France qui est le
principe de solidarité donc il faut être
pragmatique et se dire ok on veut sauver
le système sinon c'est la banqueroute
donc trouvons des solutions mais
l'opinion de Déborah reste minoritaire
dans le pays à l'heure où la chambre
haute commence l'examen du texte sur les
retraites selon notre dernier baromètre
donc ça pour ce 29% des Français se
disent favorables à un vote des
sénateurs sur le report de l'âge légal
de départ à 64 ans alors que 70% des
Français s'y opposent toujours
mais moi ça me pose pas de problème
d'aller jusqu'à 4 ans je trouve cette
jeune femme très sympathique d'abord je
ne sais pas quel âge elle est là c'est
sûr que de travailler dans un magasin
d'optique et sûrement moins épuisant que
de travailler à la chaîne dans une usine
donc voilà par ailleurs moi ce qui me
frappe dans ce qu'elle évoque c'est à
quel point la communication du
gouvernement a finalement pénétré les
esprits pourquoi dire que le régime
risque la banqueroute et tout simplement
faux c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit le
rapport du Comité d'Orientation des
Retraites son président s'est exprimé à
de nombreuses reprises et d'ailleurs ça
a été fort peu apprécié par par le
gouvernement donc c'est un problème de
recettes mais qu'il faut se poser la
question du niveau de vie des retraits
pour compléter totalement ce que j'avais
évoqué donc il évoque le fait qu'il n'y
a pas d'effondrement contrairement à ce
qui se dit et que les gens pensent parce
que le bon argument qui semble de gros
bon sens ah mais on vit plus longtemps
donc c'est normal bien sans tenir compte
de des évolutions démographiques qui
sont qu'effectivement on a tous entendu
parler du après la guerre bref tous ces
gens-là que nous adorons tous
effectivement sont aujourd'hui en face
de retraite mais un jour ne seront plus
parmi nous bref donc il y a ça ensuite
il y a la question des recettes et la
question des recettes il faut évidemment
la regarder alors on a affaire à la fois
à la droite et à Macron qui refuse la
taxation des super profits la
réintroduction de ce qu'on a appelé
rapidement l'impôt sur la fortune on
peut regarder si on peut répartir
l'effort sur à la fois les employeurs
etc donc il y a d'autres pistes de faire
travailler les gens plus plus longtemps
juste de points par rapport aux propos
de même de la Contrie
champ total des accords sur l'évolution
démographique il faut se rappeler qu'en
1945 quand le système avec le corps
le corps C o r Oui Oui
en 1945
en 1945 quand le système de répartition
est intégré par le général de Gaulle on
avait 6 actifs pour un retraité donc 6
actifs financés une retraite aujourd'hui
on en est à 1,7 la trajectoire 2040
aujourd'hui c'est 1,4 il y a un pic
démographique mais là c'est pas le corps
qui le dit c'est l'INSEE en 2040 ce qui
veut dire clairement qu'on aura moins
30% d'actifs à partir de 2040
et donc l'idée c'est de dire si on a
moins d'actif on aura forcément moins de
cotisants et derrière ce sont les
pensions de retraite qui baisseront
on peut parler des recettes vous parlez
c'est mon deuxième point vous parlez des
super profits mais vous avez déjà tenté
de taxer les riches regardez entre 2012
et 2015 vous augmentez massivement les
impôts qu'est-ce qui se passe dans cette
période là vous avez des recettes
fiscales qui chutent considérablement
moins 2% derrière vous avez plus de la
moitié des personnes de plus quand un
revenu imposable de plus de 100000 euros
qui quittent la France donc vous voyez
bien que c'est un peu la courbe de
l'affaire dès lors que vous matraquez
fiscalement vous arrivez à un seuil
d'acceptabilité qui fait que vous aurez
mécaniquement des délocalisations des
chefs d'entreprise qui n'ont plus
investir et donc à forceuri plus
d'emplois l'emploi qui finance les
retraites futures
mais non mais c'est le discours on va
l'entendre pendant des jours et des
jours c'est le discours traditionnel de
la droite encore une fois si on veut
augmenter les recettes il faut vraiment
lire les travaux de Michael Zemmour qui
a révélé la supercherie de la fameuse
pension à 1200 euros au premier à tous
que les gens ont compris comme étant
assuré
ce qui a été un flop du gouvernement
incroyable bref donc il y a plusieurs
façons de manière subtile fine et pas
matraquer le terme est sympathique mais
il n'est pas exact pour augmenter les
recettes de la même manière que ces
illusoire de penser que parce qu'on va
augmenter retarder l'âge de départ à la
retraite toutes ces personnes doivent
être en emploi quand on regarde les
courbes d'emploi des seniors on voit
bien que on va amener des gens ça marche
très bien pour repousser l'âge de départ
à la retraite ça marche très bien pour
les cadres sauf que plus vous êtes peu
qualifié plus en fait vous n'avez plus
d'emploi donc vous retrouvez au chômage
avec une réforme du chômage qui comme
vous le savez est extrêmement rude pour
les personnes concernées et ensuite qui
vont finir pendant quelques temps sans
activité sans ressources peut être au
RSA donc ça c'est un naufrage j'ai du
mal en fait j'ai du mal à vous
comprendre parce que en 2014 vous faites
une réforme qui s'appelle la réforme
Touraine qui la chose suivante il va
falloir travailler davantage ce que vous
prenez les 43 ans nuités donc quand vous
êtes au gouvernement oui mais vous
cotisiez davantage donc vous travaillez
davantage on est le pays d'Europe qui
travaille au moins 170 heures par
rapport à la moyenne des pays des pays
européens c'est un constat donc en fait
dès lors que vous êtes aux affaires vous
avez un principe de réalité qui vous
rattrape et comme vous êtes dans
l'opposition vous dénoncez clairement le
ce principe de réalité et c'est là où
j'ai du mal à j'ai du mal à vous suivre
à nous c'est les économistes Michael
Zemmour c'est pas c'est pas un
parlementaire de gauche vous avez bel et
bien sûr en 2014 la réforme Touraine
dans la même logique qui était augmenté
la durée de cotisation c'est une chose
de manière progressive retarder l'âge de
départ c'est autre chose mais mais c'est
un filet de sécurité là je vous ai par
ça évite les les petites ça évite les
petites pensions effectivement par
rapport uniquement à à la durée de
cotisation
des femmes seront-elles pénalisées par
cette réforme avant de vous entendre
Stéphanie pierre de la Gontrie Samia la
droite sénatoriale a proposé des
amendements sur ce sujet oui elle
conditionne même son vote elle
l'adoption d'une surcote pour la
retraite des femmes ayant tu un ou
plusieurs enfants elles auraient droit à
une majoration sur les trimestres
cotisés après 63 ans attention elle ne
pourront pas partir pour autant à la
retraite avant l'âge légal prévu par la
réforme qui est à 64 ans mais c'est à 63
ans elles ont une carrière complète et
qu'elles ont eu un enfant chaque
trimestre supplémentaire travaillait
après 63 ans sera majoré de 1,25%. donc
pour une année supplémentaire travaillée
entre 63 et 64 ans ça fait quatre
trimestres majorées et donc ça fait au
final une surcote de 5% c'est une ligne
rouge pour la droite l'adoption de cette
de cette surcote pour les pour les pour
les femmes vous conditionnez votre votre
réellement à l'adoption de cette mesure
totalement je vous lisions
d'introduction je pense que les maires
de famille sont les grandes perdantes de
cette réforme en tout cas sur le texte
initial
des femmes en général mais du texte
initial du gouvernement donc on a des
propositions très fortes en faveur des
maires de famille je pense que là dessus
la gauche
sera favorable à ce qu'on à ce qu'on
examine ses amendements et je pense que
ce sont des dépenses effectivement
supplémentaires puisqu'on parle
d'équilibre je m'entendais monsieur
Patriat tout à l'heure
c'est quelque chose aussi qu'il faut
dire aux Français ça me tient à cœur si
vous permettez
tout ce système de répartition
ne tient que par rapport à la vision
démographique que l'on a de notre pays
mais dans cinq ans ou dans 10 ans il
faut dire aussi la vérité il va falloir
en revenir il y a d'ailleurs une clause
de revoyure dans le texte à 5 ou 10 ans
et ce qui veut dire qu'il va falloir
être imaginatif et proposer aussi un
autre système
que le système de répartition qu'on
adossera à ce système de répartition
pour pouvoir pérenniser notre système de
retraite parce que
on va revenir sur les femmes allez-y
parce que vous vous dites vous on voit
bien que c'était
injuste sur certaines sur certaines
dispositions on va essayer de le
corriger et j'espère encore une fois
qu'on aura la gauche avec nous sur les
avancées sociales que la droite pourra
pour apporter mais encore une fois
attention parce que notre objectif c'est
bien l'équilibre en 2030 et donc tout
dépend social doit être compensé par une
recette on vous entend la tue est-ce que
vous allez soutenir les républicains sur
la question de la surcote Marie-Pierre
les républicains sont en fait comment
dire leur ligne rouge sur les femmes moi
j'ai écouté les déclarations du
président de leur groupe parle de
politique nataliste faire simple
et donc dit il faut traduire dans les
textes nous nous allons sur ces sujets
comme sur d'autres faire en sorte que
les inégalités soient
comment dire corriger c'est pour ça que
je me permettais de vous reprendre c'est
pas que les maires de famille enfin
c'est très c'est très bien j'ai des
enfants formidables mais attendez je ne
vais pas vous dire aujourd'hui il y a
4000 amendements donc permettez-moi de
vous dire à l'instant que oui le sujet
des femmes est important pas que les
maires de famille parce que les femmes
sont les grandes perdantes quand on
regarde ces Jérôme guedjka révélé cette
situation c'est les économies souhaitées
par le gouvernement c'est les femmes qui
est supportable 60% dans le régime dans
ce qui est proposé dans cette réforme
parce que les femmes ont des plus petits
salaires ont des carrières hachées etc
etc et donc c'est elle qui trinque dans
cette dans cette réforme au-delà de
qu'elles connaissent déjà donc les
maires de famille c'est très bien mais
il y a pas que les maires de famille
donc on va regarder tout ça peut-être
que nous le voterons peut-être pas
peut-être que nous proposons quelque
chose de plus intéressant
des femmes maintenant on va parler des
régimes spéciaux non encore une fois
enfin moi ce qui est important c'est que
il faut gommer sur la politique
nataliste effectivement ce que la
question
ma pensée première sur la procédure qui
a été employée on devrait proposer un
nouveau contrat social aux Français et
là on a une réforme où il y a qu'un seul
prisme c'est le prisme comptable et
effectivement la politique familiale est
un sujet notre politique fiscale est un
autre sujet en fait on ne peut pas
aborder l'ensemble des sujets qui qui
sont inhérents à un système de retraite
également les injustices sociales qui
peuvent être dégagées de ce système de
contrôle du système passe par une
politique nataliste est-ce que c'est ça
que vous défendre évidemment puisque on
voit très bien que l'évolution
démographique du pays fait qu'on a un
vieillissement de la population
pour sauver le système de retraite de
deux choses l'une soit notre taux de
natalité dynamique pour pouvoir avoir
des générations qui permettent le
financement des retraites à l'avenir
soit c'est une politique d'immigration
et Jean-Paul Delevoye qu'il faut faire
des enfants premièrement et il faut
mettre en place la capitalisation c'est
renoncer au régime par répartition je
résume ce que vous avez non non non
c'est pas c'est très caricatural de ce
que vous évoquez
on voit bien que le système de
répartition ne pourra être pérennisé que
si on indoce un système de capitalisme
on est en désaccord on peut on peut en
discuter
dans cinq ans ou dans 10 ans et toujours
sortir la même musique aux Français en
disant il va falloir pérenniser notre
système de répartition donc on va vous
demander de travailler de travailler
davantage ce n'est pas votre cas pardon
mais si bien sûr que si le système de
répartition il doit garantir une
retraite minimum pour tous aujourd'hui
il y a 8 millions de Français qui ont
déjà un système de capitalisation
3,5 dans le public 4,5 dans le privé
c'est un juste généralement ce sont les
plus aisés qui peuvent prendre cette
option là de capitalisation nous ce
qu'on veut c'est que ça concerne tout le
monde même les revenus les plus modestes
et que les taux de cotisations peuvent
varier en fonction d'évolution du
salaire vous voyez donc c'est pas c'est
pas si caricatural que vous ne dites
nous verrons ça en séance
du dernier point il y en a beaucoup à
mais on peut pas tout faire les régimes
spéciaux c'est l'un des points les plus
inflammables de cette réforme cela
suppression progressive de ces régimes
se fait sur sa mère oui qui permettent
aux salariés de certaines branches de
partir plus tôt à la retraite la réforme
du gouvernement prévoit déjà de les
supprimer mais pour les nouveaux
entrants ceux qui seront embauchés après
la réforme la droite sénatoriale
voudrait que ça aille plus vite elle
voudrait une accélération de cette
suppression dès 2025 pour intégrer au
régime général ceux qui ont été
embauchés avant la réforme mais vos
alliés du centre ils ne sont pas
d'accord avec vous Hervé Marseille l'a
rappelé hier sur ce plateau regardez
c'est quand même un sujet qui est quand
même assez explosif il se passe des
choses de cette mars que les
républicains veuillent avoir des
marqueurs de droite parce qu'ils disent
nous sommes de droite et donc nous
défendons des propositions de droite
pour les électeurs de droite moi j'y
vois pas d'inconvénients mais nous on a
des marqueurs au centre alors vos alliés
centrices ne vous suivent pas sur
l'accélération de la suppression des
régions spéciaux est-ce que la droite va
défendre ses propres amendements en
séance pour pour l'accélération
parler d'équilibre en 2030 et des
avancées sociales il faudra les financer
et c'est l'une des pistes de financement
je rappellerai juste à Hervé Marseille
que dans l'amendement dit Savary qui a
été voté pendant 4 ans il y avait cette
accélération du calendrier des régimes
spéciaux donc je pense que on arrivera
un accord avec les centres
j'imagine non mais parce que si vous
voulez sur les régimes spéciaux c'est
très intéressant parce que on mélange un
petit peu plusieurs sujets certains
effectivement enfin ça ne saute pas aux
yeux les motifs pour lesquels
aujourd'hui on devrait les conserver
pour d'autres c'est beaucoup plus
justifié en raison de la de la
pénibilité particulière de leur de leur
travail mais pour nous il y a une
question de contrat social et pas que
social c'est-à-dire que quand vous
rentrez dans une branche d'activités les
modalités de retraite font partie des
des voilà du contrat à passer bon et
donc nous nous ne sommes pas d'accord
pour que les règles du jeu soient
changées en cours de route mais au-delà
de ça ce qui va être intéressant c'est
de voir quelle est la position
sur notre proposition de retravailler
par exemple sur ce que certains
appellent à tort régime spécial le
retraites des sénateurs c'est-à-dire que
ce n'est pas un régime spécial c'est un
régime autonome nous l'auto-finançons
tout ça est exact sauf que nous avons
nous allons déposer l'ensemble des
groupes de gauche une proposition de
résolution pour que le Sénat se prononce
sur le fait de savoir si oui ou non il
faut retravailler cette question est-ce
qu'on peut nous sénateurs s'extraire de
la réforme en cours si elle était votée
donc nous nous opposons nous à la à la
suppression de régime spéciaux encore
une fois certains effectivement
sont peut-être plutôt aussi
indispensables que pour apparaître parce
que c'est le contrat social passé et
ensuite nous attendons avec intérêt la
position des sénateurs LR sur la
question de la retraite des sénateurs je
suis ravie d'entendre qu'il faut
différencier des certains régimes
spéciaux d'autres après se posent la
question des critères de pénibilité
Emmanuel Macron en 2018 supprimer
certains critères de
absolument
pas et là je vous rejoins
excusez-moi c'est intéressant ce que
vous dites parce que c'était à la
demande des entreprises est-ce que ça
veut dire que vous allez être d'accord
sur le retour des critères pénibilité il
faudrait il faudrait étudier le cas mais
encore une fois l'un ne va pas sans
l'autre d'ailleurs supprimer des régimes
spéciaux sans rien trop dire les notions
de critères de pénibilité je pense que
ça déséquilibre le texte sur le régime
autonome des sénateurs on applique les
réformes à chaque fois qu'elles sont
votées on repousse l'âge de il faut il
faut le dire aussi c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui c'est 62 demain la retraite
d'un sénateur c'est 64 aurait juste dire
si on aligne l'âge de départ moyen en
retraite d'un sénateur c'est 72 ans et
on cotise plus de 20% sur sur nos
indemnités donc tout n'est pas
comparable non plus non est-ce que vous
voulez dire que donc vous ne serez pas
d'accord pour qu'on réétudie le sujet
écoutez pour l'instant nous on est sur
cette ligne de s'appliquer la réforme
par rapport à l'âge de départ légal
c'est-à-dire qu'on repoussera la
perception de la première lettre
retraite d'un
sénateurs ce serait toujours courtois
mais toujours combien et on l'a vu
dans le respect l'un de l'autre on
pourrait essayer avec nous on va
regarder ce qu'elle a une de nos
quotidiens régionaux
[Musique]